hello good afternoon you're watching ask
Inez at 12 and we're starting this hour
with some breaking news
police in Bradford are searching for a
14 year old student who's accused of
stabbing a teacher so let's just show
you the live pictures of the scene now
where police are obviously there in
force at the school the incident
happened a few hours ago just before 9
o'clock this morning at Dixon's Kings
Academy in Bradford the 50 year old
teacher who was involved has been taken
to hospital and is being described as
having a wound to his body he has said
though to be in a stable condition
the police are describing it as a very
serious incident so let's find out a
little bit more about it at Sky's
Charlotte low-mass is here with us so
Charlotte what details do we have of
this incident
well yeah West Yorkshire Police now are
urgently looking to find a 14 year old
pupil in connection with this incident
he's described as Asian with a short
dark hair and was last seen wearing a
blue uniform blazer so they're now West
Yorkshire Police as you can tell from
the scene of their at the school they're
there to try and reassure pupils and
staff they're saying at this stage in
the investigation they don't believe
that there is any risk posed to staff
and people as you can imagine there's
been lots of parents arriving at the
school wanting to know what is happening
and also we've seen a policeman with a
dog searching waste ground next door to
the school and that was just around
11:30 this morning we've also had a
statement from West Yorkshire Police
which I can read to you now we are
conducting inquiries in the area to
locate a suspect and I would like to
reassure residents and staff that all
necessary resources are being deployed
to investigate this ongoing and clearly
very serious incident we would like to
hear from anyone who witnessed the
incident or knows the whereabouts of the
suspect and